many people regard driving on beaches as
a harmless summertime tradition but for
others it's a threat to safety
and the environment our mega lovers in
Amagansett New York part of East Hampton
town where a potential legal battle over
beach driving is gearing up Meg good
morning Margaret good morning there's a
stretch of Anna peak beach behind me
that stretches less than a mile it has
become a battleground between homeowners
and truck drivers people have been
allowed to drive up and park there for
decades an age-old tradition that people
who live along that Beach are hoping the
courts will finally stop tucked away on
the east end of Long Island the Hamptons
pristine beaches and brisk waves help
cool off this summer heat
but tensions in one town are boiling hot
over an age-old tradition driving on the
beach there are just so many trucks and
it's dangerous and it's very crowded and
loud and there's alcohol and I just
don't expose my children to that and
homeowners Jennifer Ford and Cindy crane
live within walking distance of Napa
beach in East Hampton a small stretch of
it less than a mile allows trucks they
want to ban them altogether it feels
like a parking lot doesn't you like the
beach
it's an impossible situation and it's an
accident waiting to happen
home videos show some close calls in one
a truck narrowly misses a child no one
has been seriously hurt here but for
many it's a big fear I have a son who
was on the autism spectrum and he has
very limited impulse control so he's
he's someone who wouldn't necessarily
think ahead that there might be an
accident at Ormond Beach in Florida last
month the pickup truck ran over a
four-year-old boy causing serious
injuries trucks packed tightly together
on beaches across the country an
off-road ritual from North Carolina and
Georgia to Texas and beyond your kids
grew up coming to this Beach they
literally grew up on this Beach Loree
pasa modo has been driving on Nappi
Beach for decades did you always feel
safe having them on the beach with the
truckscouts 50-year history of people
driving on the beach people come out
here every Sunday town trustee bill
Taylor spent decades patrolling the
speech in East Hampton he says it gives
locals who don't live within walking
distance a chance to enjoy it Taylor
says the homeowners who live along the
beach don't just want to ban on trucks
they want to make it private I think
that if they could have this too
trying to beat you would make their
real-estate incredibly you think this is
a monetary thing I think that's a factor
some people might say that you're just
trying to privatize the beach our issue
is about safety children's lives are at
stake so you don't want to privatize it
no no the legal fight over who owns the
beach continues in November a judge
ruled in favor of the town trustees but
for homeowners like Cindy and Jennifer
the fight is not over their homeowners
association is in the process of
appealing again to ban the trucks glad
Meg thank you